¿Están listos?
Venga. Rock rebelde, rock rebelde, rock.
Rock rebelde, rock rebelde, rock.
Esto sí que es una fiesta. ¡Venga!
(Música)
(Solo de saxofón)
Necesito que todos lo hagan. Todo el mundo, vamos.
(Cantando) Canta, rebelde del soul.
Rebelde, rock rebelde.
Canta, rebelde del soul.
Canta, rebelde del soul...
Rebelde, rock rebelde...
Rebelde, rock rebelde.
Canta, rebelde del soul...
A ver, un segundo.
Todos diciendo: "Chuh chuh chuh chuh chuh, chuh chuh chuh,
chuh chuh chuh chuh chuh chuh chuh ..."
Todo el mundo diciendo: "A bailar sin parar".
A bailar sin parar.
Vamos, dije que los rebeldes a bailar.
Los rebeldes a bailar.
Todos digan: "Marcando el ritmo, el ritmo, el ritmo."
Marcando el ritmo, el ritmo, el ritmo.
Los Soul Rebels se mueven.
Es el hip hop.
Venga. Los Soul Rebels se mueven.
Los Soul Rebels se mueven.
Es el hip hop.
Aquí en TED esta noche.
Todo el mundo, venga.
(Cantando) Canta, rebelde del soul...
Rebelde, rock rebelde.
Canta, rebelde del soul...
Vamos.
(Música)
(Aplauso y ovaciones)
¡Eso es!
Un fuerte aplauso
para Paul Robertson en el trombón.
(Aplauso y ovaciones)
Corey Peyton en el trombón.
Marcus "Red" Hubbard en la trompeta.
(Aplauso y ovaciones)
Julian Gosin en la trompeta.
Lumar LeBlanc en el redoblante.
(Aplauso y ovaciones)
Manuel Perkinson en el sousáfono.
Derrick "Oops" Moss en el bombo y percusión.
(Aplauso y ovaciones)
Erion Williams en el saxofón tenor.
¿Se lo están pasando bien todos está noche?
(Ovaciones)
Vamos a tocar otra más para Uds.,
un tema original titulado "Rebel On That Level".
Sigan con las palmas, todos. Lo noto, venga.
(Dando palmas)
(Música)
(Solo de trombón)
(Solo de trompeta)
(Música)
(Fin de música) (Aplauso y ovaciones)
Gracias, señoras y señores. Los Soul Rebels. ¡Gracias!
(Aplauso)